you you are famous to most people who
will know you as one of the writers from
the TV show The Simpsons you know I
wrote a book I wrote A Memoir my 30
years at The Simpsons to be candid one
reason I wrote this book was to get
fired I just said all right I'm gonna
you know I'll do this book I won't ask
anyone and they'll fire me and finally I
can move on with my life but the book
just turned out to be a love letter to
The Simpsons and it was only then I
realized oh yeah there's no dirt 35
years
and there were maybe two bad weeks and
35 years where people were not getting
along you know I mean it's a microcosm
of what a good corporate culture is
supposed to be that if you all get along
and share with values and have common
cause it should work